I just found out like a couple months
ago that like my dad isn't like my
actual dad and my mom has just been like
straight up lying for like 18 years to
my face and like I found it out because
I was getting documents for like college
and I was like just like medical [ __ ]
and like I said the name and all my
dad's name it was like different and so
I got on my mom and I'm like yo like why
is it different she goes oh it must be
like a typo or like they messed it up or
some [ __ ] and I was like oh all right
then and then so my friend called me
like a week later and he goes yeah bro
your mom got drunk and told my mom that
you're not your dad's son
at home was like yo what the [ __ ] and so
like I go on a trip whoa so what dude I
feel like the clues are adding up kind
of a little I'm sorry to hear this
that you're not the dad's son you are
not the son
you are not the son
the dad's like
um but bro you are you at the beach or
something because it's you're like bro
my dad you know he didn't know and I
told my mom she's like what
and then I feel like I'm talking to Chad
and JT this could be a Chad and JT prank
um but I'm a rod imma Rod let's hear
more and I'm sorry I'm well I don't I
can't tell how this is affecting you yet
it's like my cousins and [ __ ] and I'm I
open up to him I'm like yo I don't think
my dad is my real dad and they go yeah
we know that we then knew that and like
everyone in my whole life knew
bro
are you sure you didn't are you sure
it sounds like
you should have known I hate to say that
but
it sounds like everybody like hey this
isn't my real dad and people are like no
[ __ ] what oh no I mean was there moments
where you were like
where you got like a Christmas present
from him and it was like
um
two my son love Dad question mark
like did anything like that ever happen
or were you ever in the house and you
were like Dad
and he was like not it like did you did
you hear any memories because
it just sounds you're like Mom it's not
our real Dan she's like I don't know Bob
might be a typo I mean is and are you
guys eating weed or something let's hear
more
and like everyone in my whole life knew
everyone knew and no one told me my mom
ever lying to me and I just didn't talk
to her for days and I'm just like for
days bro this whole thing I think this
is Chad and JT and if it is dude
ah
you guys pretty good man we didn't you
know I almost like it's in your dad man
and I was like uh
uh
oh
if it's not brother if this is not as
pranked and I am I am sorry I'm sorry
but also you got a new adventure baby
you out there
you know
you got to you're that [ __ ] Sherlock
homie bro you out there you could go
[ __ ] get you a new dad
find that new you know that and this Dad
could be a you know you got a chance to
really it's almost like I'll trade
what's that what's here but you know
it's like Let's Make a Deal
all right Ron or whatever I'll give you
you know I'll give you you know uh Alan
or whatever the dad's name is and I'll
take a chance for what's behind door
number seven or whatever so good luck
out there bro a lot of us you know you
get the dad you get and you don't get
that second opportunity so this could be
God really doing something powerful for
you
and I think you got to pay attention too
bro it sounds like people been trying to
tell you it was on your birth
certificate your cousin's all new people
were shocked when you didn't know
I think you got to drop in dude and look
at just some baby pictures and stuff and
see who
the man is that's next to your mom
and I think
it's gonna blow your mind dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one